when should you register your company so
I got a great question from one of my
YouTube viewers Ollie love you guys who
wrote in to say hi having great advice
as usual thanks for that a quick
question I'm going to launch your
website at what stage should I register
a company should the company be named
after the website or shall I create a
different company name and make my site
a product of that company
thanks again Cheers Ali from New Zealand
so paints Ali for writing in if you know
that you're gonna start a business and
it makes sense to go and register a
company what I would do it is try to
match the website to the company name
and when I'm starting new businesses are
investing in the companies we usually
name the company when we can find a
website first the web having an
available domain name is hard to find
right to get the dot-com right now is
super hard and so we'll try to find a
domain name that works and then name the
company after that as well you know you
don't have to make the match it's just
easier right your website is one of the
most powerful tools that you have now to
market your company and if you go out to
somebody and you're you're you know how
to trade show or you're talking about
your business and you say yeah I've
started this company you know Ali's
great company and then I go and I go to
Ali's great company and it doesn't exist
or worse somebody else owns a dot-com
I'm type in Ali's great company calm and
it's going somewhere else that's
misleading for customers right and so
it's possible you can make that work
it's just confusing and hard for the
customer so if confusion is part of your
brand then it can work but otherwise I'd
recommend making things easy try to find
the dot-com domain name buy it and then
name your company after that as well
believe so those are watching let me
know you think leave a comment
underneath if you like these videos you
can support me by clicking on the link
in the description and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon